from varian let's listen to his question
hi jason my name is verin i'm from
sydney australia
and my startup is property ml where
we're focused on
delivering the most accurate property
valuation model
using ai my question to you is
centered around startups outside of the
us
and what i wanted to ask you is
generally speaking do you find that
startups outside the us are
rushing too fast to get to the us
instead of
taking advantage of the local market
that they're familiar with
or on the flip side are you finding that
they actually aren't showing enough
urgency to get to the us
and to unlock that large market which
would be
much larger than the one they operate in
thanks jason
all right great great question so one of
the
amazing advantages that uh founders in
australia
canada ireland um and let's call them
the smaller under 100 million people
under 50 million in fact uh in your case
25 million people live in australia i
believe
uh ireland is what is it five or ten
million uh canada's 25 30 million
one of the great advantages you have is
you can build an english
language app let's say you were going to
build robinhood the trading app
i happen to be lucky enough to be an
angel investor in that one i'm not sure
if i was the third of the fourth but
let's put that aside for a second
and you wanted to launch robin hood you
wanted to try free trading
well how different are people in canada
than the us
ireland then canada australia new
zealand
these markets are generally going to
behave similar they're not exact
but you can grow itself so what many
companies do is when they want to make a
big change like a big company
like facebook they will test that change
in australia because people in america
can't see the australian app store
and they're not allowed to download
those apps so it's a great way to a b
test so your question is should i when
when do i how do i time that
well if you think you have a killer idea
and you want to go stealthy
and you don't want the press to know
about it the american press
they're under resourced they're not
getting a burner phone from canada and
going into the canadian app store they
might they might
some savvy ones use something like a vpn
to look at websites from different
regions and see if there's some
differences so
i think if it's all about learning your
customer
and if you and what kind of investors
you want so let's let's break that into
two parts
if you want american investors uh
you're going to need to be able to prove
that you can
address the largest markets in the world
and americans
are very self absorbed and
know their market so we happen to have a
lot of uh
investors here in america on the
investor front
building in australia and then sharing
those results with an american investor
and saying
don't tell anybody but we figured it out
in australia look at the engagement
we have this ai product look at what
retail look at what real estate
executives are saying about our product
in australia
it doesn't exist in america and we're
gonna bring it there and you get a first
shot at it
that's kind of a cool cool little
stealthy way to do it and after canva
uh who was on the podcast and atlassian
people are looking to australia and
saying there are
great investments to be had so i think
that's the strategy you want to play
you figure it out there then you
approach american investors when you're
at that
you know for this american investor who
has an um the launch accelerator
i'd i'd like to know when you hit five
to ten okay a month even australian
dollars that's fine with me they're
still dollars